so let's just do a quick review to make
sure you know things make sense so we
started from Maxwell's equations and
then we said that uh basically for any
uh antenna or more generally for any uh
current distribution and space we can
find the electric and magnetic fields
and the way it works is let's say you
have some antenna with some geometry it
can be 2D 3D whatever it is and then
at some point R in space we want to find
our electric Fields electric and
magnetic fields so first we start by
solving for the magnetic Vector
potential a
and a is found by solving basically this
integral so the integral has a constant
mu over 4 pi and then it the integral is
is carried over a volume in a space that
contains the current distribution so if
you have this antenna you want to
basically make sure you integrate over
the entire you know uh shape of the
antenna and then what do what is the
integrand the integrand is the current
distribution on the antenna so that's
the J is the basically electric current
density in amps per meters squared at
point R Prime what is r Prime R Prime is
the point on the antenna that we
basically that's the variable of the
integration we are changing uh R Prime
Times This this term e to the minus J
Norm k r over R and this as as as you
know what is this this is a spherical
wave
and uh D cubed R is a a infinitesim only
small volume basically element
uh so so once you solve this integral
and the Assumption here is uh that uh
excitation current basically or how we
are the current that we're generating on
the antenna is uh has a harmonic form so
the time basically variation of it is
like a pure sinusoid it has like a e to
the J2 Pi ft time and that's why there's
no time in here if you're only basically
doing everything over space because the
time portion we're fixing it to be a
pure harmonic that's that's uh the
Assumption here so with that we can
solve for a
uh so if uh the the basically full
function for a which is a function of uh
space and time is the space portion
which is giving the by this integral
times the time portion which as I said
we are assuming it's a pure harmonic e
to the J 2 pi ft if it's not if our
current J uh is not varying um as like
harmonically uh we also last time looked
at a more uh General version of this
integral which also had t in it and that
always works okay
so what's so that's the first step then
what do we do uh from the from a which
is the magnetic Vector potential we can
find electric and magnetic fields how do
we do that you plug your a into the
Maxwell's equations and then uh we
showed you how you can um there from
that uh find your e and H there's no uh
integrals anymore so that's that's just
you need to calculate some partial
derivatives like the curls and
divergences and things like that which
are typically very straightforward but
that's how you get from E from a to e
and H okay so now we have our electric
and magnetic fields now what we're
really interested in is basically how
are we radiating uh energy uh into space
or power into a space what is the
distribution of electromagnetic power in
the space from from this antenna okay
because that that pattern of basically
radiation determines uh what what we can
see what is the field of view uh and and
how much uh Echo we will get from
targets at different basically angles
so the first quantity once we have our e
and H that we usually calculate is the
so-called average power flux density so
that is basically the flux of power
which is in watts per uh per unit area
watts per meter is squared and that s
it's also called the pointing Vector
as average is is equal to one half the
real part of the vector cross product of
the electric field and the conjugate the
complex conjugate of the magnetic field
H okay so this is also once we have our
enh this is pretty straightforward to
calculate right it's just that these are
two R3 vectors we just do the cross
product and take the real part and
that's our RS note that s is a vector
right so it's not just
how much power watts per meter is a
squared there's also a direction
associated with it because that power
flux in what direction is it flowing
okay so s here is is a a vector but the
units of the the amplitude two of s is
in watts per meters a squared now um
from there we also said that when you
look at the radiations from an antenna
there is basically different regimes
that you can look at in terms of how far
away you are from the antenna we in
sensing we are interested most of the
time not 100 of them but most of them
especially in robotics I can say uh
almost all always we're interested in
the so-called far field and that's where
your distance to the antenna is bigger
than 2D squared over Lambda where Big T
is the largest dimension of your antenna
so if for instance it's a micro strip
antenna it would be the length of that
micro strip or if it's a
reflector antenna like a dish would be
the diameter of that dish basically so
that's your D divided by Lambda which is
the wavelength okay and again for for if
you we plugged in some you know typical
numbers for uh use cases in autonomy
like a Lambda that was like a few
millimeters for say a 77 gigahertz radar
and a d that was like a also a few
millimeters and it turns out that you
know it's far field but physically you
don't need to be that far usually like a
few inches away is already considered
far field why is far field important
because certain simplifications apply
like in the far field our electric and
magnetic fields uh turn out to be
orthogonal to each other and also the
fields can be very well approximated by
plane waves that are only traveling
radially outwards uh uh with respect to
the antenna so if this is my antenna
then in the far field basically my my uh
phase fronts of the of the fields are
can be approximated as planes and the
direction is radially outwards at every
point in the space so that's basically
the simplification that happens when we
do the far field approximation and then
in the far field regime the the uh uh
Power flux density becomes equal to the
the square of the the magnitude of the
field at Theta and Phi and Theta and Phi
are basically the Azimuth and the
elevation angles at the point that we
are basically observing so the magnitude
squared divided by 2 times ETA is a
constant called the impedance of the
medium times the the basically the
distance is squared right so what this
tells us is that our power flux density
in the far field there is a basically
fall off that is one over distance is
squared right and then the angular
dependency of it is entirely determined
by our e field right and our e field we
already know it because we found it here
so we can basically in the far field
very well basically approximate our
power flux density okay
and then this one over range of square
drop off should make sense because if
you're in the far field you can kind of
assume you know things are
these uh you have these like big spheres
for the for the for the waves which are
locally kind of flat that's why locally
it it looks like a plane wave but if you
look at a much larger scale these are
kind of like very big
spherical waves at the far field and
then the power is kind of like being
distributed on the surface of the sphere
and the surface area of a sphere is
proportional to r squared so that's why
you get the one over r squared drop off
in your power density okay so uh this is
this is okay but usually we don't want
to you know involve the the distance
when we talk about uh
radiations so instead of working with
the power flux density we usually work
with radiation intensity or the
radiation pattern of the antenna it's
the exact same thing except instead of
looking at Power per unit area
radiation intensity calculates power per
unit solid angle okay and then solid
angle it doesn't depend on range right
it's the same if you look at the cone of
solid angle it's always the same thing
no matter how far away you are from that
and then we showed that this radiation
intensity or radiation pattern is simply
given by the the distance is squared
like Norm squared of R and times the
magnitude of the power flux density
magnitude of this okay so in terms of
the electric field it simply becomes
magnitude of the squared of e of theta
and Phi divided by two ETA and now the
units is watts per Ester radian instead
of watts per meter there's a square
that's the radian is a unit solid angle
and this U is now just a scalar right
there's no directionality so associated
with it it's just the flow of power in a
unit basically a solid angle
so from this for instance we can
calculate total radiated power how do we
do that if to if you want to find the
total power that the antenna is
radiating you just assume some closed
volume around your antenna a closed
surface basically call that big Sigma
and your antenna is somewhere in there
and then if we integrate the the
radiation pattern
on that entire surface Sigma that gives
the total power that is being radiated
and you integrate over solid angles of
course so that in Watts basically this
gives you the total power that is
radiating out out of that volume Sigma
or Surface Sigma is this clear
so far
okay so then we started looking at you
know what what are what does the this U
look like what does the radiation
pattern of different antennas look like
okay as a function of theta and Phi and
this is uh essentially the same thing we
did for uh uh sonar in sonar we also
looked at basically what we call the
beam pattern of a sonar transducer the
analog of that for radar becomes the
radiation pattern of a radar antenna
simplest one is uh the isotropic antenna
uh which basically radiates completely
uh symmetrically in the 3D space which
means the the radiation pattern uh
basically looks like a sphere so it's
always constant regardless of what Theta
and and Phi is so U of theta and Phi for
isotropic antenna is just use zero
okay and then for that if you calculate
the total radiated power you basically
integrate a constant u0 over the solid
angles so you can take the u0 out of the
integral and the integral of just D
Omega is the total solid angle for a
enclosed basically surface which is four
PI right it's like the total solid angle
of a of a full sphere if you will so the
total radiated power would just be uh
the the radiation pattern use 0 times 4
Pi or the other way around your u0 you
can calculate it as the total radiated
power divided by 4 Pi now note that
isotropic antennas it's uh it's just a
um it's a mathematically ideal case that
is never physically possible like
there's no antenna that anyone can build
that would perfectly you know radiate
isotropically any antenna that you can
physically build it would have you know
some preferred Direction and a space for
its radiation so here's like one example
example of a non-isotropic antenna which
has like a main lobe of radiation and a
bunch of side lobes so most of the
energy would be
basically radiating inside the main lobe
and then the silos would also have some
energy and there is some directions
where the where you have the nulls and
in those directions like in this
direction and in that direction in space
actually no energy flows for for that uh
grayish radiation pattern that that
we're showing here
okay so isotropic antenna is is one but
now for instance if you if you look at
horn antennas and last time I had one
that that they actually uh looked at uh
these have very uh uh very directional
radiation patterns so for horn antennas
actually the the axis of the horn most
of the energy would be uh focused
towards that one thing that is quite
common uh when it comes to describing
radiation patterns uh sometimes instead
of giving the full you know uh youth uh
Theta and Phi as a full function of
Azimuth and elevation sometimes uh only
the two cross sections in in two
orthogonal planes are given so basically
like for for this radiation pattern here
you might only be given you know a cross
section of it in the horizontal plane
that I'm showing in in red and a cross
section in the vertical plane that is
would be the green one and sometimes
those are called the E field and the
e-plane and the h-plane radiation
pattern because we know in the far field
enh or orthogonal that's just it's not a
complete description of the radiation
pattern but it's good enough for most
applications you just do two cross
sections and into 2D plots you can
describe what the radiation pattern is
uh but in reality remember it's to fully
describe the radiation pattern it's uh
you need the full
um you know 3D either in shape of a in
form of a plot or a function or you look
up table you need to as a function of
the Theta and Phi you need the full
description now what determines the
radiation pattern of an antenna there's
basically two factors one is geometry
you know the shape of the antenna the
length of you know different parts of
the antenna especially in relationship
to the wavelength as at which it's
radiating okay so it's like and there's
that relationship between the size or
the geometry of the antenna and the
wavelength uh and and that basically
determines your radiation pattern here
is a simple one we are looking at a
dipole antenna and a dipole antenna
remember it's just two wires right it's
just two straight rods or wires that are
connected to some signal source that is
say oscillating sinusoid or generating
this sinusoidal current and it's being
fed so this feed line or the
transmission line can be a trace on a
PCB or a coaxial cable you're somehow
feeding the antenna and then we assume
that the two sides have the same length
call that L over two
and then we are looking at the radiation
pattern for two two cases one is where
the length is equal to half of the
wavelength at Lambda over two and that's
this case and here as you see the
radiation pattern looks like a donut
and uh just make sure it's clear the
antenna here is aligned with the z-axis
and it's placed at the origin okay so
that's I highlighted it in red and
that's that's where so this basically
what it tells you is that there is no
power flowing in the Z Direction that's
just that's a null of your radiation
pattern so right on top of the Axis or
at the bottom of the axis of the antenna
you you you won't get any radiation so
that's one and now if you change the
length of the antenna or alternatively
if you change the wavelength of the
signal that you're feeding it the Lambda
such that L equals uh one half Lambda
three Lambda over two the radiation
pattern completely changes now you still
have your main lobe kind of like around
this but now you add this side lobe also
so so geometry the shape of the antenna
and also the dimension of of the antenna
with respect to to the wavelength those
two together determine the radiation
pattern
now another antenna related parameter
that is kind of useful is the so-called
directivity of of the antenna so what
the directivity does is that so we have
this ideal antenna which we call the
isotropic antenna but any other antenna
has is non-isotropic so it has some not
asymmetric radiation pattern so uh their
activity is basically the ratio of the
radiation intensity of of the antenna to
that of an isotropic antenna so it kind
of comp tells you it's a measure of how
asymmetric the radiation pattern of your
antenna is how is it calculated very
simple so it's called D of theta and Phi
and what you do you just divide
basically radiation intensity or
radiation pattern of your antenna by
that of a isotropic antenna isotropic
antenna just has a constant u0 radiation
the density has been also it's just your
U divided by U zero in terms of the
radiated power remember u0 was p over 4
Pi so you can write it as 4 Pi U over
the total radiated power so that's the
directivity and it's a dimensionless
quantity it just tells you the larger
the D is in a certain direction that
means a lot of power is getting radiated
in that direction sometimes you just
take the max of the directivity over all
angles all Theta and Phi angles and that
Max basically gives you the the
for the direction that most power is
getting radiated how much more than an
isotropic antenna basically are you are
you radiating here here's an example
this is an overlay of two radiation
patterns so that's why it looks a little
funny but you have the sphere which is
the isotropic antenna and then we're
overlaying it with a dipole antenna
which is this donut looking thing so the
cross section is like you have the
circle and then you have your little
do not like sangi cross section for the
dipole antenna and then the the
directivity like the maximum directivity
ends up to be being like 1.67 in the
direction that where your maximum power
flow is for the for the dipole antenna
it's just a way of you know measuring
how uh how directive as the term
suggests your radiation pattern of the
of the antenna is
okay one more uh parameter is called the
radiation efficiency of uh of of of the
antenna which is so remember the
antennas are being fed by some circuit
right so you feed it some electric
current so some electric power is being
fed to the antenna called that PN but
not all of that power would get radiated
only some of it would get radiated some
of it might get uh like turned into
thermal losses or might get reflected
back into the circuit so radiation
efficiency is basically the ratio of how
much power you radiate over how much
power you fed to your antenna so here's
a picture so you have some source that
is generating the electric current or
the electric voltage you have a
transmission line that connects the
source to the antenna again this could
be a trace on a PCB or coaxial cable or
any means of basically feeding the
signal to the antenna so at the antenna
criminals there is some electric power
PN being fed into it but not all of it
would radiate out only some fraction of
it would become radiated power and that
fraction is called the radiation
efficiency right so it's a number that's
always less than one and it tells you
how efficiently your your
um antenna is converting that electric
power to radiate it power
basically
and then there's uh this notion of the
antenna gain
and the antenna gain is basically the
ratio of the uh radiation intensity of
the antenna to the radiation intensity
that you would have obtained if all the
input power to the antenna all of PN was
radiated isotropically
okay let's make sure this makes sense
it's it's like okay you have an antenna
it has some radiation pad in you
how does that compare to an ideal
antenna that has an efficiency of one so
all the power you feed to it it's
radiating and it's also radiating it
isotropically that ratio is called the
antenna gain it's called G of theta and
Phi and a very simple expression for it
so the numerator is is just U of theta
and the denominator if you have an
isotropic antenna with an efficiency of
one it's radiation intensity is just
going to be p in over 4 PI right that's
that's what it is so you divide the two
you get that expression you can also
write it in terms of the directivity it
becomes equal to radiation efficiency
times the derivativity of your antenna
and that's again this is an important
one I mean these are all as you see
equivalent they're just you know the
everything from uh from s right on these
are all equivalent like these are just
scaled versions different scalings of
the same quantities which describe how
power is getting radiated out so you
have your pointing Vector s then you
have your antenna radiation intensity or
radiation efficiency you have your
directivity and now you have your gain
if you have one of these you can
calculate all the others by just you
know applying different different scale
factors but
um historically the one that is uh most
of the times reported so if you buy an
antenna and you look at the data sheet
they usually give you the gain and
that's the one they report okay so
that's why I wanted to make sure you
understand what is gain and how is it
related to other you know quantities or
parameters that are defined for antennas
but usually again you look at any data
sheet and they show you the gain of of
the antenna here's one a real example of
a radar system on a PCB so this is a 77
gigahertz
radar system the antennas are microstrip
antennas and the wavelength at 77
gigahertz ends up being 3.9 millimeters
so let me zoom in on this first so we
can take a closer look together so you
have the red PCB these four
blackish icsuc these are fully
integrated radar transceivers so they
have all your TX circuitry and all your
Rx so they generate you know the
waveforms they have the amplifiers you
know on the transmit side and then on
the received side you know they have
your down converters and filters and
adcs and all that each of these has uh
three transmit channels and four
received channels and then on the PCB
you have the micro strip antenna so each
of these interesting looking patterns
with four you know squarish patches on
it each of these is an antenna and then
the antenna is being fed you see that
that Trace that's the trace on the PCB
that is coming from the IC and that's
one of your transmit traces so as you
see each of these has three transmitters
coming out and one two three four
receivers coming out so overall because
you have four of these ICS you end up
with a system that has 12 transmit
channels 12 transmit antennas and all
those 12 are you know you see them all
here one two three four five six and so
on and then you would get a total of 16
receive antennas so there's a group of
four a group of four and a group of
eight here for a total of 16. okay so
it's a full system
and then if you just look at one of
these antennas
uh that's the in blue I've I've shown
the the full pattern of it so basically
you feed it from here that's that's
where the signal comes in the trace of
the PCB and then your antenna has a
total length of 9.17 millimeters and a
width of 1.4 millimeters so it has a
very asymmetric design in in one axis
it's pretty long right and the other
axis it's pretty skinny that's how the
antenna is and then the gain of of this
antenna which is also you can think of
it as a radiation pattern is shown here
here we should we see the two cross
sections so these are from the data
sheet of actually this radar that they
they show this let's zoom in so there is
there's two plots the red is like the
horizontal cross section or the or the H
plane cross section of the gain and the
purple-ish is the vertical cross section
or the or the e-plane basically cross
section of the gain and here on the
right you see the full 3d plot of the
you know the surface of what G of of
theta and Phi uh looks like now here's
something very very interesting
um
so let's let's look at this if you
compare the H plane again h-plane is the
horizontal cross section of the gain and
the purple e is the vertical cross
section you would see that the gain is
it has a much wider gain pattern
in the horizontal direction right so it
goes from like minus 60 degrees to 60
degrees and then only after that again
starts dropping in the horizontal plane
right and the vertical plane it's pretty
narrow right it's only I don't know
maybe like
plus minus like seven or eight degrees
or maybe 10 degrees and then very
quickly your gain drops right so your
radiation pattern is very narrow in in
in vertical and very Broad and
horizontal okay and that's a very
important basically design decision that
the engineers who designed this this
antenna basically made and why is that
so this is specific radar is a radar
design for automotive applications so it
is designed as a reference design to be
mounted on cars okay for automotive
applications like self-driving cars and
things like that so the environment that
these radar is is going to be used at
what do you want to sense so it's a car
on the road you're not interested in
things in the sky and also below you
there is the road you're not interested
in you know things that are under the
surface of the road right so you want
that's why you want to focus most of
your energy vertically in a very narrow
beam so you only see you know cars and
buildings and things around you around
the Horizon but horizontally you want a
very wide beam pattern right we want to
be able to see things for as wide as
possible look ideally they would have
loved to have a full 180 degrees but
that's not physically possible so they
got close to it like 120 degrees or so
so that was
at design so it's not just you know it
just randomly happened to have this
radiation pattern people thought about
okay what is the use case of this
antenna what are we going to send uh
need to sense and then they designed a
geometry that gives them a radiation
pattern that is that is desirable and
also from the geometry it makes sure
makes sense because you see horizontally
that the antenna has a very small
aperture and if you remember from the
discussion and sonar small aperture size
means wide radiation right so
horizontally it's a small antenna right
so you get wide radiation horizontally
and vertically it's a very long antenna
right it has a what big there's almost
like a factor of five difference in the
vertical Dimension and the horizontal
Dimension so vertically it has a big
aperture which means you get a narrow
radiation pattern very quickly okay so I
hope this makes sense but also I think
at this point you should feel confident
that you know if I just gave you this
antenna geometry and the wavelength you
should be able to you know do the full
analysis and get to the point where you
can you know fully plot the the gain
pattern of of the antenna how do you do
that again everything that's on the
board you start from the antenna
geometry you find your a from on the a
you find electric and magnetic fields e
and H from E and H you find your s and
then from the S you can find U and
ultimately the gain of course you
wouldn't do any of this manually there's
like software tools or you like write
code yourself but the process should be
hopefully pretty clear for you
any questions
yes
the calling the vertical plane to be H
in the horizontal to be e is that like
by Design or is it I think that's kind
of arbitrary I don't think there's like
real physical it's not related to the
magnetic or electric field right
let me think about that there might be
actually some physical
significance to it
like
for there's no
like you could change the names and
nothing would would change right like
everything would work out but why do
they call the horizontal H and the
vertical e is there like
does it have something to do with the
polarization of the fields coming out of
the antenna maybe I have to think about
that yeah
um I'll I'll get back to you on that
okay
so
um the last thing about antenna so
everything we talked about so far was
about antennas as transmitters right we
were just talking about you know the
radiation pattern and you know how how
the power is distributed but antennas
also can act as receivers right and
there's one important parameter that
captures that effectiveness of the
antenna as a receiver and that is called
the effective area of the antenna so
what the effective area describes is is
basically how well the antenna is going
to capture the power in a received Echo
okay and the way that is uh
characterized is by this parameter
effective area which is the ratio of the
power that the antenna will deliver
to the receiver circuitry at its
terminals call that PS okay so that's
the power again this antenna is now
being acting as a receiver so the power
that it will deliver to the to the
receiver circuitry divided by the power
flux density of the wave that is
incident on the antenna the echo wave
that hits the antenna that's carrying
some power flux density so that ratio of
how much power it will deliver to the
flux density that is incident on it and
it will have the units of area meters
squared because your numerator is power
and Watts the denominator is watts per
square meters so you end up with a
quantity that is in in units of square
meters and that's the effective area of
the antenna now it turns out that
um
if the echo is coming from a Target that
is in the far field there's a very
simple relationship between the
effective area of the antenna and the
gain of the antenna and that's given by
this formula here so if your target is
at the far field basically the
simplifying assumption is that uh
um the echo that's received that's
getting to the antenna is plane waves
because we're so far away from the
target we can approximate it by plane
waves and then your effective area would
be given by wavelength squared divided
by 4 pi times the gain pattern of of the
antennasuff it depends on the direction
that the echo is coming from you don't
have a constant effective area it's a
function of theta and Phi because you
don't have except if your antenna was
isotropic where G wouldn't depend on
Theta and Phi but for every physical
antenna your
power capturing efficiency depends on
the angle of incidence of the return
Echo okay
so I think this kind of is is everything
that like we finished the discussion
about the antennas now we know you know
how how they operate both as
transmitters and receivers and how can
you calculate basically different
important physical parameters associated
with with antennas now we're gonna use
all this
uh and hopefully at this point I can
convince you that we didn't do here
physics just for the fun of physics or
for the pain of physics but this is
really useful for sensing so we are
going to use all this and do something
very useful which is uh basically
find that how what is the maximum range
maximum theoretical range that a radar
can sense basically for a given set of
parameters like transmit power and
receive power and gain of the antenna
and and wavelengths and so on and so
forth how far can you see with the radar
and that is the the idea behind the
radar range equation it's a very simple
calculation so what what we're going to
assume is we're going to assume we're
working with a monostatic radar what
monostatic radar is means that the
transmit antenna and the receive antenna
are placed almost at the same place
they're almost co-located they're very
close to each other okay so that's one
assumption we're going to make it's a
it's a monostatic and or or it could be
even the same antenna it's just one
antenna acting as both receive and a
transmit
antennas at location R Prime there is a
target at location r
and the target bearing or DOA angle call
that Theta Target and Phi Target and
here always the assumption is that
targets that are far away would scatter
all the power that's incident on them
isotropically okay so we assume that
it's kind of like the the small Target
approximation okay so uh here's kind of
like a picture you have your your radar
antenna of course this is not a radar
for autonomy but the picture I thought
was cool to show something different so
here's your radar antenna it has some
radiation pattern right or a gain
pattern and then there is some Target at
location R and then once we hit the
target the target Echoes are going to uh
basically be distributed isotropically
or it's actually like
spherical waves that the target Echoes
back and knows the spherical waves
because the target is so far away by the
time they they reach back the the
receive antenna they're kind of
approximated as plane waves that's
basically the setup of the problem that
we're trying to solve so the first thing
we can calculate is what is the
radiation power density that hits the
target okay that's very easy right let's
call that W incident w i for incident
that's just a magnitude of the pointing
Vector at the Target location by
definition that's how much power or the
power density will hit the target
and as we know that's just given by
U the radiation pattern at angle Theta T
Phi T divided by r squared r is the
distance between the the Target and the
radar okay we can also write it in terms
of the gain of the of the antenna again
I'm just reusing everything we derived
before there's no new physics here I'm
just you know plugging things in to do
something useful with it so in terms of
the gain we can write it as a g of theta
T Phi T times the PTX TX is the total
transmit power total power that we put
into the waveform divided by 4 pi r
squared so this has units of watts per
meters squared and it's a power density
that is hitting the target which is at a
range r
okay now the target is going to Echo
back some of this power not all of it
but some of it is going to get echoed
back and the amount of power that is
getting echoed back that PS is is uh
some constant Sigma times the incident
power density so this PS now has units
of Watts it's the total power that the
target Echoes back and this Sigma is
called the target radar cross section or
RCS and it's a very famous term in in in
in in radar and it has units of area
meters is squared and it effectively
tells you how much power the target will
go back it's kind of like the RF
reflectivity of the target if you will
but it has the units of area because it
needs to give us the total power in
Watts when Once multiplied by the power
density that's incident on the target so
for example there's you know tables that
or curves that gives you
rcss of different types of targets at
different wavelengths it depends on at
three things basically determine the RCs
there is the size of the target of
course how big they are the material
that they're made of like metallic for
instance targets typically have larger
cross sections and the wavelength at
which we are operating so it's a
function of three things so example like
an adult male has a
um on average has a RCS of one one
squared meters in the K Band and K Band
is like the 77 gigahertz frequency that
these Radars operate at okay so so far
we have calculated total power that the
target is going to Echo back from that
if we assume that total power PS is is
radiated back isotropically again it's
kind of like in spherical waves it's
it's coming back towards us what is the
power density received by the antenna So
the antenna how much power do we receive
it's the total power that the target
radiates back divide it by 4 pi r
squared y 4 pi r squared because 4 pi r
squared is the area of a sphere with a
radius R and if we assume the power is
radiated isotropically it means we get
just a constant power density on the
surface of this sphere so back at the
receiver so this is received power
density
from the target it's just PS over 4 pi r
squared plug everything in we get this
expression it's the transmit Power Times
the gain times the target cross section
divided by 4 pi squared r to the fourth
and this now has units of watts per
meter squared that's the power density
you have one more thing to calculate
okay this is the incident power
um density how much power would the
antenna actually deliver to Our receiver
circuitry and that as We Know by
definition so the power delivered to the
received Electronics is just the antenna
effective area times the incident
um Power density so plug in the
expression for a effective and make that
plane wave approximation for the echo
that's come back to us we end up with
this expression which is the transmit
Power Times the squares we now have the
square of the gain times Lambda squared
times the radar cross section of the
target divided by four pi cubed times R
to the fourth and this in watts is now
the total power that we have in the
receiver Electronics so this is the
signal that then we need to use to do
sensing with the power of the signal
that we use there's one more thing we
should include in this so nowhere in our
analysis here we factored in losses we
know there's losses there's losses
propagation losses in in air there's
also losses in the electronics and you
know other parts of the system so we
also should include that to do a full
analysis and we are going to lump in all
the sources of losses into just one loss
parameter called that L and that's just
one number less than one which kind of
factors in all the losses that that we
have throughout the system and this is
then the final expression for the
received power uh on the radar
Electronics so again it's like
transmitted Power Times the square of
the gain times Lambda squared times
cross-section of the target times losses
divided by 4 pi cubed R to the fourth
okay now uh if you're interested say if
you're interested in okay how far can we
see with this radar what is the maximum
R fix everything else what is the
maximum range that we can sense so if
you solve for R this is what you get so
R would become like this expression
which has the transmit power in the
numerator uh the receive power in the
denominator and everything else to the
power of one-fourth one thing to note
this is not we are not talking about
this is not an algorithm for for doing
ranging right this is just an analysis
of you know the trade-offs in the system
and the sensitivity and you know to
establish an upper bound on how far we
can see this analysis is helpful so um
to get something very actionable out of
this say for a given radar system if you
know what is the minimum receive power
that the radar can detect right based on
you know the noise level and the
algorithm items and everything you might
know what is the minimum PRX that you
can work with for sensing if you plug
that in and everything else would also
be known so your transmit power say you
decide on it and you know it the gain of
your antenna you know your antenna
geometry so you can plug that in Lambda
you know that's your operational
wavelength you can assume some Target
cross sections so let's say I want to
see how far I can see a human with a
radar cross section of one square meters
you also plug in your losses and that
would give you basically the maximum
range for that choice of Target and
wavelength and gain and power and and
everything and that's why it's called
the radar range equation so just to
summarize
if you know the minimum
power
that your radar can detect it's
basically the sensitivity of your radar
and then you can plug that plus
everything else into this expression it
can tell you the maximum range
theoretical maximum range that you can
sense with that radar with that choice
of uh parameters again it's like an
upper bound it doesn't guarantee that
you would see always up to that range
for that choice of you know Target and
angle and everything else it's sort of
like establishes an upper bound you can
never go above this basically maybe you
can get close to it and with good DSP
and and everything else another thing
that is kind of interesting in here is
that you know this power of 1 4
makes it really tricky to increase range
by just increasing power because for
instance sometimes you might think oh if
I want to see further I'll just send out
more power right send out more power I
can I can I can see further out well you
you yes but not by as much as you would
think because the power is raised to the
power of one-fourth so if you double the
power for instance you're only going to
increase your I by 19 uh our maximum
range by 19 so increasing power is not a
very effective way or an efficient way
of you know increasing the maximum range
of your radar
okay
any questions
all right so hopefully at this point by
seeing this it kind of justifies that
all the things physics that we did
especially to see how you find the gain
of an antenna from you know the geometry
and wavelengths and other other
parameters and all the physics that we
did they're actually useful for sensing
because for instance you can do an
analysis like this and estimate what is
the maximum range that a radar can see
okay
so I think this is basically all the
physics that that we needed to know to
be able to analyze and understand Radars
at a system level so now we're going to
start looking at radar systems and talk
about signal processing algorithms
um for uh sensing so again here the
physics would be very useful for us
because we're going to use the physics
to build a very realistic signal model
and then we use that signal model to
develop our DSP algorithms so starting
with uh basically the radar system block
diagram this is kind of like a generic
block diagram of a of a radar system it
should look very familiar you know the
elements of it it should be the same
things we saw for instance in in sonar
or in GPS also so you have some waveform
generator always and call that waveform
sft and then you have a so-called local
oscillator so that basically generates a
carrier frequency for you which is the
center frequency of your radar God so
just some pure sine wave it could be at
whatever the operational frequency of
your radar is say 24 gigahertz or 77
gigahertz or something and then you up
convert your waveform uh to the carrier
frequency you pass that through a
amplifier and that gives you your
transmitted signal basically ST which is
the gain of the amplifier times the the
waveform that you generated times the
carrier okay and that goes to an antenna
this uh interesting looking device here
called the circulator it's basically
like a three port device I intentionally
put it there because not every system
uses it actually many Radars don't use
it but I wanted you to see it once
because some Radars do use it and it's a
three port device the way it works is
that it's kind of like a directional
coupler so if you feed it as signal in
Port one pretty much all of it goes to
Port two
if you've heated a signal in Port 2
pretty much off it goes to Port 3 and if
you feed the signal in Port 3 all of it
goes to Port one so it's exactly like a
circulator so then uh the way it
operates here is it can basically
separate out the transmitted and the
under received signal in the transmit
path all the signal goes from one to two
and that's the power you radiate out and
then when you receive an echo that if
you use the same antenna if it's like a
monostatic radar using the same antenna
all the signal is going to into Port 2
and then out of port 3 and then goes
into the receiver chain which has its
own amplifier and as usual I received
signal Sr is just an attenuated and
delayed version of the transmitted
signal St times this term which is the
Doppler shift and and we're gonna talk a
lot more about it but this e to the J Pi
J2 Pi f d t FD is the Doppler shift
frequency that we're going to talk about
but what happens then is you amplify it
through a low noise amplifier and then
you have your down converter block which
basically takes your uh receive signal
and either the local oscillator or the
modulated local oscillator and it gives
you some if signal you filter that you
digitize that through the ADC and then
the rest or pretty much all the magic
happens in DSP for Radars as as we'll
see so we're going to spend a lot of
time talking about this block
um but that's basically at a high level
the block diagram it's you know
different systems there's variations of
it so some systems don't have a
circulator they use separate transmit
receive antennas some systems as we'll
see use multiple transmitted multiple
receive antennas some systems don't use
like older ones don't use like adcs they
somehow have analog circuitry for if
we're doing ranging and so on and so
forth but this generally
captures the essence of what a radar
system block diagram should look like
okay let's do a bit of taxonomy on
Radars just like we did for sonar so in
terms of the waveforms that we transmit
exactly like sonar there's there's two
classes of radar one is the pulse radar
and this is the exact you know analog of
pulse Echo sonar what it does it's also
called pulse Doppler radar or pulse Echo
radar so it transmits short pulses
waveforms and then the transmit uh is
for the most part silent and just uh
hearing for for The Echoes coming back
and there's many different types of
pulses used in these systems and simple
ones more advanced ones and to do
ranging they either do simple
thresholding or match filtering exactly
like sonar right we covered this in
detail when we were talking uh in sonar
these also can do velocity estimation by
measuring that Doppler shift and we'll
talk more about this and the direction
of arrival estimation they either have
antennas with very narrow gain patterns
very directional antennas and then they
physically scan the antenna to to do
directional rewards so basically there
the assumption is whatever angle the
antenna is pointing to I'm only sensing
in that direction because it's a very
narrow beam and two sense in a different
direction I move physically my antenna
so for instance on the on the airports
if you've seen these rotating you know
parabolic antennas those are doing you
know physical scanning to determine uh
direction of arrival or they can also do
it in Signal processing using some idea
called beam forming we'll we'll talk
about that also later then you have your
CW your continuous wave radar
this is kind of the analog of the ctfm
sonar and
the waveforms here well first they
continuously transmit right they're
never silent they're just over and over
uh sending the waveforms without uh
stopping and then the waveforms are
either frequency or phase modulated if
they're frequency modulated it's called
the fmcw radar frequency modulated
continuous wave and then if it's phase
modulated it's called a pmcw or phase
modulator CW radar
um they have overall they have better
properties than than pulse radar so
pulse rate are pretty much is not used
for robotics it uses in other
applications like military Aviation and
so on robotics pretty much always we use
a continuous wave radar
um so um what's good about them is that
they have You Know Better Properties
like better resolution smaller size no
moving parts and things like that the CW
radar but they need more advanced DSP so
the complexity basically shifts to the
digital domain and DSP for the CW radar
but that's okay because these days we
have very capable compute platforms
always for these robots so we can handle
complex DSP
uh fmcw radar
uh basically it's exactly like ctfm
sonar so it sends these linear frequency
chips and uses those for ranging pmcw it
operates exactly like the GPS so it uses
PRN codes so uh to do you know ranging
based on correlations so both of these
you kind of have seen before you know
how they they're gonna operate but again
as usual the devil is in the details so
we'll see there is details are specific
to radar which makes the DSP very
different say from sonar or GPS
and they can also estimate velocity
based on the Doppler shift and the
direction of arrival again they can do
physical scanning but in robotics
usually the DOA is also done via a
technique called digital beam forming in
DSP and we'll talk about digital beam
forming a lot so that's the the two
types in terms of the waveforms and
here's a high level picture showing you
you know what these waveforms look like
pulse radar again it sure sends these
short pulses at some pulse repetition
rate and for the most part it's not
translating anything then you have your
fmcw radar which sends these frequency
chips right it ramps the frequency
linearly and then it repeats sends
another one and another one continuously
and then here's a pmcw radar with binary
phase modulation and this one is taking
the carrier and it's doing a bpsk binary
phase modulation of of the carrier phase
with a say a PRN code that you're very
familiar with so it's basically
multiplying the carrier by these like
plus ones and minus ones which are
basically the the PRN code and that's
the phase modulation that it applies so
this is basically one code word then
and then it sends it again and again and
again and uses correlations to do
ranging
okay uh now there's another way you can
basically uh categorize Radars and
that's in terms of the number of
antennas that they use so you can have
systems which are called single input
single output or siso systems and they
just have a single TX antenna and a
single RX antenna uh and uh the only way
such systems the only way they can do
direction of arrivals estimation is by
physically scanning the antenna there is
no other way if you only have a single
TX single RX there's nothing you can do
when it comes to direction of arrival
estimation there's nothing you can do in
DSP
your only hope is to use very
directional antennas and physically scan
them and again an example is like the
airport surveillance Radars or asrs they
have these parabolic antennas that they
rotate and these are very directional so
which is a single antenna they can also
do a direction of arrival estimation
which is the angle the antenna is
pointing to then you have mimo systems
or multiple input multiple output
and this is what will
study in detail and these have multiple
TXS multiple rxs and they can use that
to do the OA estimation without any
physical scanning so you can do that
purely in in DSP they can also work with
any any kind of antennas so the antennas
don't need to be very directional so
they can the antennas can be almost
isotropic for instance in the mimo
systems and an example is again like the
automotive radar we looked at a few
slides back that was a mimo system it
had 12 transmitters and 16 receivers
lastly there's a a classification of
Radars in terms of the antenna
configuration or placement again I told
you about monostatic that's the radar
where the txrx antennas are either the
same or they're co-located very closely
and then you can have biostatic Radars
when you're transmit and receive
antennas are quite separated
okay so these are like we did like the
full taxonomy there was like a pulse
rate or continuous wave radar
single input single up output
multi-input multi-output and also
monostatic by Static
what is which of these are most useful
for autonomy applications uh and it
turns out that the mimo Radars either
fmcw or pmcw are the ones that are most
uh uh basically best fit for robotic uh
autonomy why because they can offer very
high range they can offer very high
direction of rival or angular resolution
they typically can have very small form
factors especially the ones at higher
frequencies can have small form factors
they don't they don't require any moving
Parts they are low power
consumption and you can especially if
you use uh these micro strip antennas
you can integrate the entire radar
system in a single PCB like the one you
saw last time in class and that makes
them you know very desirable for robotic
applications
um
now between fmcw and pmcw
uh today almost like 99 of radar systems
that are commercially available RPM fmcw
systems
um there's already integrated
transceivers available uh and and uh
their their shipping in large volumes
pmcw uh I really personally like the
idea I think it's a it's a better
architecture
um but for uh practical reasons
um today these systems uh tend to be
more costly to manufacture and because
of that most manufacturers uh picked up
basically fmcw as a technology to focus
on I'm sure in a few years you would see
more and more you know pncw systems but
today there's not that many of them
there's one company I know of in in
Texas uh called under that that builds
basically pmcw systems and they don't
sell them to General Public they just
have exclusive contracts with some
customers but for fmcw there's many
companies and you can you know buy
either full systems from them or just
transceivers and design your own
antennas so because of that we will
focus mostly on fmcw we will talk about
pmcw radar we won't drop it but not in
as much depth although the the slides
will covered in full depth but we
wouldn't in class go go through it all
because it's not as relevant today in a
few years it might change now what type
of performance we can get from these
radar systems and these numbers here
these are you know state-of-the-art
numbers typical but specific systems you
know are going to are going to be
different but you can get ranges of
several hundred meters for instance
especially at 77 gigahertz with a
resolution of few tens of centimeters so
good resolution very high range now some
systems claim more than this I've seen
systems that claim up to like 800 meters
range for robotics field of views that
are can be pretty wide like horizontally
150 degrees vertically 50 degrees with
the angular resolution of some sub 1
degree is these days achievable with
good DSP and then you can they can sense
very high velocities up to like plus
minus 90 miles per hour with a velocity
resolution of half a mile per hour
measurement rates a few tens of Hertz
and they are pretty low power
consumption like in a few tens of Watts
again there's lots of trade-offs
involved so you usually cannot hit all
these numbers simultaneously you would
have to pick and choose according to
your application for instance if you
require very long range you might need
to give up on the maximum velocity that
you can sense or if you need a high
velocity resolution you might need to
give up on your range resolution we will
study all these trade-offs so it's not
like all of these simultaneously are met
but these are kind of you know the
boundaries of what what these systems
can do again these are these numbers are
very specific to Mimo fmcw radar systems
used in robotic applications in other
applications people like in in in
defense people can see hundreds of miles
with their Radars right but there's no
free launch like something is is going
to give to enable that long range
basically but for robotics the state of
the art today these numbers are are
achievable any questions
okay so uh here's one example of a um
again we're talking about like fmcw
systems these days are commercially
available so you can go
um online today and buy this chip from
TI called
awr2243 it's a fully integrated three by
four mimo fmcw radar 3 transmit four
receivers it can operate in the K Band
from 76 to 81 gigahertz and this is the
full system brought diagram that slide
with the red PCB that I showed you where
we studied the antennas the chips the
transceivers where these
awr2243s there and here uh we now should
be able to understand most of what's
shown in this block diagram let's trace
it together so it has a ramp generator
so this is going to generate those
frequency chips
that's that's the part of the circuit
that does that and then that is being
fed into a frequency synthesizer so
that's like the local oscillator first
they do it at 20 gigahertz okay and then
this is being fed into a frequency
multiplier times four so that's how they
can get up to 80 81 gigahertz they they
basically quadruple the frequency after
modulating with chips so what comes out
of this is basically our our St right
which is St of T which is the waveform
that is modulated uh with a with a
carrier frequency of up to 81 gigahertz
they have phase control if you want to
do like active phase control we'll talk
about this but we didn't include this
block in our block diagram and then it
goes into a power amplifier and outcomes
a RF signal ready to be fed to your
transmitter antennas antennas are
outside the chip so you have to you know
make them on a PCB or a
in a different way and then on the
receive side you have your low noise
amplifier you have your down converter
and then here's a uh basically a low
pass filter and then it goes into an ADC
so it's it's exactly the same block
diagram that that we looked at together
so to build a radar system with this
basically all you need to do is
basically hook up some antennas to it
which could be microstrip antennas on a
PCB and also this doesn't do the DSP for
you so you get ADC output interface so
your raw signal out of the ADC the
digitized signal comes out and then you
have to feed it to your own DSP block
which can be a computer or a fpga or
some other microcontrol or something
that can do digital signal processing
for you but that's all you need to do to
build a full radar system
um you buy the chip you integrate I mean
of course you have to like feed it power
and you know the usual stuff for the
electronic to work like a Chris
oscillator and power and this and that
but at a system level really all it
needs is antennas and DSP everything
else is integrated in this tiny you know
few millimeter by three millimeter chip
for you that costs
few tens of dollars really really cheap
and that's why fmcw is so dominant pmcw
is not at this maturity level because
mainly because of cost reasons basically
the cost of the the requirements of pmcw
systems is specifically the adcs need to
be very high sampling rate like Giga
samples per second which makes them
expensive to make what the process is
today I'm sure in a few years that's
going to change and hopefully in 10 15
years we can have chips like this that
do pmcw also okay so let's uh we're
gonna start with looking at fmcw radar
DSP and specifically how you can
estimate range and velocity in fmcw
systems and then we'll do the same for
pmcw
but again remember fmcw you're gonna go
full depth like no no stones on Trend
like we're gonna do do it you know in
painful detail pmcw we wouldn't go as
much in depth okay so uh here's our
system block diagram specific to fmcw
systems most of it is the same as the
general uh block diagram but a few
differences here our waveforms are these
linear uh frequency chips that we had
seen in uh sonar uh op converted and
then fmcw systems because these are CWU
systems
um uh you can reuse the same antenna for
for transmit and receive so they
typically use a separate transmit
antenna and a separate receive antenna
so on the transmit side this is the
signal we transmit is the gain of the
amplifier times the chirp signal times
the carrier and at the receive receive
srft which is attenuation times the
transmitted
waveform that is delayed by the round
trip time of flight Tau times this
Doppler shift term which we'll see where
it is coming from you feed it through
the amplifier and through the down
converter down converter exactly like
the case of sonar it's being fed by the
receive signal and not the not the pure
Lo but the full you know transmit a full
modulated transmitted chip so the other
input to the down converter is St times
e to the J 2 pi fct this is exactly the
same as sonar and then we get this if
frequency signal out hopefully the hope
is that this signal would have some
frequency Delta F which is is
proportional to the round trip time of
flight Tau so if we estimate the
frequency of this signal from that we
get the round trip time of flight and
then from the time of flight we can
estimate range like sonar right that's
that's the hope but in practice how it's
done we filter that we digitize it
through the ADC we get the digitized
version and then we do it in digital
signal processing
first thing we should talk about is what
is this Doppler thing that is different
this is something that we didn't
consider in sonar but here we're talking
about it so let's see where where this
Doppler effect is is coming from to
study that
uh we can abstract out the details of
the waveform so let's let's assume
there's there's no actual like chip
modulation or you know or PRN codes or
whatever let's assume the radar is just
transmitting a unmodulated carrier okay
so the the signal that radar is
transmitting is just a pure sine wave e
to the J 2 pi fct okay and here's that's
that's the radar transmitter it's
hitting some Target and then some Echo
is coming back to the radar okay so what
we receive as usual is some attenuation
Factor Alpha times the delayed version
of what we transmit by the round trip
time of flight and if you plug in the
Tau what we the receive signal is given
by this expression Alpha e to the J 2 pi
FC T minus this 2R over C that's our Tau
where R is the range so 2 times R is the
round trip distance and then 2R over the
speed of light is the round trip delay
which is tall okay
now what changes is that if the the
radar or the Target or both of them are
moving
then what happens is that this R changes
with time it's not a constant anymore so
it becomes R of t
if there's movement involved right so in
that case the signal that you receive is
is going to be given by this expression
you still have Alpha e to the J 2 pi fct
that doesn't change but now you have
this time varying phase term Phi of T
which is exactly coming from the fact
that this term is now time banging
instead of 2R over c as a constant we
have two R of T over C so that phase
term Phi is minus 4 Pi FC R of t
over see now you have a time varying
phase if things are moving okay so what
well so what now what happens is that
with that time varying phase term if we
calculate the instantaneous frequency of
the signal that we receive we are going
to see that it's not just a carrier
frequency it's carrier frequency plus a
shift that is the Doppler shift so let's
do that again as you know the
instantaneous frequency of the signal is
just one over two pi times the
derivative of its face what is and and
here we're talking about this signal the
receive signal what is the phase there
is a 2 pi fct plus this Phi of T so take
the time derivative of that the first
one just gives you FC right 2 pi fct D
DT you just get 2 pi FC divide by 2 pi
it just gives you FC
that's expected right but now you get
this additional term minus 2 VR over c
times FC what is VR VR is the derivative
of range r dot and we are calling it VR
because by definition the derivative of
the range is like the radial the
relative radial velocity between the the
radar and the target that's r dot right
so now if VR is not non-zero if there's
some relative radial movement between
the Target and the receiver that's going
to induce a shift and the frequency in
the instantaneous frequency of the
signal that you receive that's called
the Doppler shift
so the Doppler shift is equal to -2 VR
over c times FC and we all know the
carry frequency FC is speed of light
over wavelength so if you can also write
that as a function of the wavelength so
your Doppler shift is minus two times
the radial velocity divided by the
wavelength that you're operating at and
it's in hertz okay so that's where the
Doppler effect comes from at the end of
the day also if you want
um
we can write Doppler shift in terms of
the actual positions of the radar and
the target so if radar is at position R
Prime and the targeted as position R and
these are vectors in R3 now what that
radial velocity is
um
so R now is equal to the norm of R Prime
minus r
so to calculate r dot r dot becomes
basically this exp or this expression
here which is little r dot minus little
r Prime Dot and then this dot product
with r hat which is the unit Vector
pointing from the radar to the Target is
basically projects that uh
arm r dot minus r Prime dot into the
radial Direction and that gives you the
radial velocity basically and that's
your Doppler shift
so just to summarize what we showed is
that when there is radial movement
between the the radar uh system and the
target what you receive there's three uh
basically things happening there is an
attenuation not new we had this before
right there is a delay by the round trip
time of flight so you get your
transmitted waveform at T minus Tau and
there is a Doppler shift so that's where
this e to the J 2 pi F Doppler T is
coming from so the received signal is
attenuated by Alpha delayed by Tau which
is the round trip time of flight and its
frequency shifted by the Doppler shift
FD okay
questions yes
yes in sonar one the stopper should be a
bigger Factor like it's in the speed of
this wave is lesser than you said in
sonar would it be uh let me answer that
in a minute okay uh yes so that's a very
good question I think the question is
like why didn't we talk about this in
sonar right and sonar we should also and
we know we have a Doppler shift because
I'm sure you've experienced it when you
have you're out on the street there is a
fire truck with a siren coming towards
you you hear that shift in the frequency
of the siren that is Doppler shift so it
does happen in for acoustic waves also
but we kind of ignored it and and I'll
answer that question why in a minute but
before that
let's first talk about uh the the
ranging in fmcw radar it's exactly like
sonar right so you transmit a chip
that's a green one and then you receive
a chip that's the blue one which is you
know delayed and then attenuated and
double shifted and then if you compare
the instantaneous frequency of the
transmitted and the received chip
they're gonna have a basically at the
instantaneous frequencies are going to
differ by some amount Delta F okay and
um
our signal model that now we are going
to work with is this so our transmitted
signal is just e to the J 2 pi FC plus
little B is the slew rate b t over 2
times T so if by that definition then
our instantaneous frequency goes from FC
at time 0 to FC plus the slew rate times
the Big T which is the chip duration at
time t
and then what we receive is
s of St delayed by round trip time of
flight attenuated by Alpha and Doppler
shifted okay now with this signal model
how do we estimate range and the radial
velocity or the Doppler shift that's
that's the problem we want to solve
um let's first see what we get out of
the down converter okay so the down
converter essentially multiplies the
received signal by or the complex
conjugate of the received signal by the
transmitted chip and extracts that Delta
f for you exactly as we saw in the case
of sonar so this if signal which is the
output of the down converter is Mu mu is
you can ignore it it's just a gain of
the receiver amplifier it's just a
constant okay if you don't like it just
cross it out doesn't matter by any means
for our analysis but I just included it
to have a complete signal model so it
takes the complex conjugate of received
waveform times the transmitted waveform
and then we plug in the two signal
models that we had into this you get to
complex exponentials this first one is
the conjugate of the receive waveform
and the second one is the transmitted
chip and then you simplify things I'm
going to go a couple of steps what you
get here
is the time dependence of it inside the
exponent is 2 pi times betal minus the
Doppler free shift times T and then you
get this second term which is a phase
term so we can write it as Mu times
Alpha e to the J 2 pi Delta f t plus Phi
of Tau which is our phase term what is
Delta F what is Phi so Delta f is has
two uh contributions to it there is some
f sub T that depends on the target range
or the round trip basically time of
flight so this ft is your slew rate
times Tau and we know that tau is 2R
over c r is the range C is the speed of
light so this F
T
basically determines the range right and
then Doppler shift is the Doppler shift
which as we know is proportional to the
radial velocity or the time derivative
of of range okay so here you immediately
see there is a complication right
because we were hoping that the
instantaneous frequency of the if signal
Delta F would give us range right but
now here it's there's a contribution
from range and there's a contribution
from velocity in it there's this
coupling there's two terms that go into
Delta F so if we just fft this Asif and
find the peak
would that really be range maybe not
right because range and velocity are
coupled and we need to clarify that that
complication
okay and then 5ft this is just for now
it's a phase term later it becomes very
important but this is the formula for it
is there's no time the T dependency in
it but it depends on Tau and FC and this
slew rate okay that's our it's the phase
of the if signal okay
so as I said if you look at the
frequency of the if signal what's coming
out of the
um the down converter it has its two
terms in it
ft and and and and FD for Doppler t for
target
range depends on Ft right by this
formula ft times C divided by 2 times
the slew rate and the radial velocity
depends on their Doppler shift via this
formula negative Doppler shift times
Lambda over 2 okay again this is a
complication because how can I decouple
my VR and R if I can only measure Delta
F these two are if I can only measure
one frequency how can I decouple it it
turns out that four robotic application
this coupling is almost of no uh
significance why because it turns out
that for almost all applications you
would be looking at the Doppler shift is
much much much smaller than ft and you
can assume this is zero in comparison
let's see why just to justify let's say
you're working with a 77 gigahertz radar
the slew rate is 30 megahertz per
microsecond
and range of the target is 20 meters and
the target is moving really fast 45
meters per second so this is like 100
miles an hour so it's a very fast moving
Target very close to you so I'm this is
like a worst case condition where you're
going to get a very high Doppler shift
because the velocity is very high and
you're going to get a very small ft
because R is relatively small it's just
20 meters okay but even in this case if
you plug all these numbers into
Expressions above you would see that ft
ends up being 4 megahertz versus the
Doppler shift is just 23 kilohertz so
the Doppler shift is less than one
percent of F and it's very safe to just
you know ignore it here and say my Delta
f
is equal to Ft which is equal to two
slew rate times range over C and exactly
like ctfm you can just calculate your
range from the frequency of the if
signal now back to the question uh when
we were talking about ctfm we didn't
even mention Doppler shift right and the
reason is the situation in sonar is is
is even
simpler than this like even in the case
of radar we see that when you look at
the frequency of the if signal you can
ignore Doppler because it's so small
compared to the frequency shift you get
from the range in the case of sonar
if you look at some typical numbers it
turns out that sonar we know inherently
it's suited for applications where
things are not moving fast because it's
a slow sensor right
so when you plug in the typical numbers
that you have for sonar in the case of a
sonar you would see that the Doppler
shifts that you would get are sub
kilohertz like they're so low that it's
not even worth mentioning it we didn't
even bother with it for the case of
sonar right for a case of radar it's
important because we see right now we're
looking at the frequency of the if
signal and for frequency we can ignore
Doppler but when we look at the phase
term that Phi term that we'll look at
that has a Doppler contribution that is
non-negligible but just to summarize
again when it comes to ranging range
estimation in fmcw radar we just exactly
like ctfm sonar we assume that the
frequency of the I F signal is equal to
Ft and then we can just estimate range
from that that frequency by doing Delta
F times C over over two times
B
um
what if you have multiple targets if you
have many targets that are echoing at
the same time and you receive you know
from one chip that you sent you receive
say Echoes from K different targets same
thing still works because based on the
superposition principle the signal that
you receive is like the sum of The
Echoes from all these different targets
so your if signal would just be mu times
the summation of these if terms which
have Delta F I's which are proportional
to the range of these K different
targets and each has its own phase term
again we'll talk about this phase term
later but the Delta F's are basically
the what's important for ranging here's
uh in a visual manner so if you have one
antenna with a very wide radiation
pattern so this green thing is like the
radiation pattern of your antenna it's
radiating a very wide angle and in this
case we have like three targets that are
being hit and all three are coin at the
same time at ranges R1 R2 and R3 so you
receive the green is like the chip that
you send and then you receive three
chirps with three different times of
flights Tau one Tau two Tau 3 and each
induces a frequency in the if signal
called that Delta F1 Delta F2 and Delta
F3 which are proportional to the range
of the three three targets so we can see
that if we just fft this we should see
Three Peaks at the corresponding
frequencies of the the three different
signals three different targets I think
this is a good place to stop and we'll
continue next time any questions
all right thank you very much